this episode starts with a proposition
how about we ripped the United States
and Mexico apart from each other
geographically speaking it would open up
new trade routes that would make a ton
of money for both countries and it could
create a whole new tourism industry for
cities along the canal but would that be
worth the giant price tag and could it
create political instability this is
what if and here's what would happen if
we built a canal between the US and
Mexico the us-mexico border is 3111
kilometers in length as of early 2019
approximately 2058 kilometers is
unfenced due in large part to the Rio
Grande River acting as a natural barrier
between the countries if we're going to
go ahead and build a canal along this
border this giant River seems like a
natural starting point don't you think
but before we bring our big machines
down there to expand the river maybe we
should stop and ask ourselves how is
this going to impact the surrounding
environment
the rio grande provides water to six
million people
so having ships of all sizes passing
through it and creating pollution
probably wouldn't be a good idea plus if
we were to expand the rio grande along
the border we'd be crossing through six
separate ecoregions along this stretch
there are 62 species of animals and
plants that are currently listed as
critically endangered our rio grande
canal could just be enough to push these
species over the edge from endangered to
extinct
it could also wreak havoc with seasonal
migration for some species and severely
limit food sources and mating okay I
agree this is starting to look pretty
complicated so how about we look at an
existing canal for guidance the Panama
Canal cuts across the Isthmus of Panama
connecting the Atlantic Ocean with the
Pacific Ocean using a series of locks to
adjust the changing elevations from
ocean to ocean in total fourteen
thousand ships a year make use of it
with larger cargo ships having to pay
upwards of 1 million dollars to use it
that's a lot of money that could be
funneled to North America instead if we
were to build a canal that matches the
width of the Panama Canal we'd have to
move about 53 billion cubic meters of
Earth at a price of 11 trillion dollars
and that number is just for the length
of the Rio Grande which is the shared
border from the Gulf of Mexico to El
Paso Texas the Rio Grande would need
reinforced concrete walls and barriers
installed along its shores and it would
need to be dug deeper in some areas if
we follow the operations guide of the
Panama Canal a specially trained Canal
pilot would have to navigate any large
boat for the duration of its trip
through the canal this might present
some issues since in the case of the
Panama Canal we're dealing with hours to
go across the canal whereas here it
would
days that another person has charge of
the ship we'd also have to find a way to
deal with border crossings on foot or by
car there are 47 legal points of entry
between the u.s. and Mexico sure we
could replace those with bridges but
each of those bridges would cost
approximately 600 million dollars even
though this project would bring a lot of
benefits it seems like it would bring
even more questions such as who would be
paying for all this how much would be
covered by the US and how much by Mexico
it wouldn't be economically feasible for
either country since it would cost
trillions of dollars just to finish
construction across a couple of states
to fund such a massive project could
mean taking that money from more vital
social or medical programs anything
deemed expendable by those with
interests in the canal the political
fallout from this could also be
significant we'd literally be making a
cut through North America this could
create a new source of global
instability something that may be viewed
as an us against them mentality by other
countries maybe all this international
trade talk would be easier if we just
didn't have those pesky oceans dividing
us all but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]